what's up everyone welcome to gamespot
we're here playing civilization beyond
Earth rising tide the new expansion that
will be out in a little more than a
month october knife and i'm here with co
lead designers David McDonough and will
miller how you doing how's it going good
I'm pretty excited to see this I've
heard a lot about it but you guys are
gonna show us more of the intricacies
between the new systems and how it
changes you know yeah this expansion is
huge I mean it really covers the entire
game and changes the way that beyonders
plays so if you're used to the base game
and this is your first time playing
rising tide you're going to be really
surprised at how different the game is
so we're gonna play maybe 50 or 60 turns
here and talk a talk about you know all
of the new different systems we've got
brand new biomes diplomacy hybrid
affinities a new artifact system
expanded quests water gameplay so we're
playing Duncan Hughes who's one of our
new leaders and one of his things is he
gets to land on the water so right away
we're going to see one of the new
features of the game here and that's a
big thing obviously you know the kind of
a titular thing about the expansions
that you could like a hundred percent of
the map like almost a hundred percent is
playable now because you can build
cities and move them around on the water
how does that how is that going to
affect like overall strategy and whatnot
well we wanted to make sure the water
gameplay that water tiles weren't just
blue land but we also didn't want to
change the formula so much that you had
to relearn everything when you play on
water so the basic idea is that the
resources and the distribution of
resources and how you gather yields are
a little bit different but the main
difference is that your city does not
move or sorry so your city doesn't grow
and then in the way that it does on land
it moves and that's how you get
territory so you're going to drive
literally drive your city around to gain
territory so with that small tweak it
changes the entire sort of strategic
implications of building on on the ocean
so are there benefits to having a kind
of hybrid you know land and sea
civilization or you have you found it's
better to try to focus on one or is it
just like everything else civilization
where it you know it can be whatever you
want to be if you're playing it right
you can definitely have power in both
cases so one of the big goals for us
with a quater gameplay was that we
wanted it to be seamless with Randy and
we've said this a bunch of times that
the barrier to entry to playing on the
sea should be no harder than playing on
land and that's because the seas are
every bit as powerful they're every bit
is dynamic and alive and full of
challenges and opportunities as a land
we wanted players to be able to embrace
it at whatever pace was comfortable for
them so once you could build a colonist
or in case of Duncan Hughes or if you
actually plan to fall at sea as soon as
you have the ability to settle you can
just drive right off the shore of units
become amphibious and you can play at
sea so that makes it really easy to just
kind of look at the sea is another place
to build your say of defined power so
nothing nothing is especially more
difficult easier or harder to do with
see there are some balance changes there
are things that are faster at sea and
some things that are slower for is it
for instance exploration is much faster
because ships are much faster than land
units and there's no miasma to slow you
down but the aquatic aliens are also
significantly faster too and they can be
a lot more of them they could be much
tougher than the ones you see on land so
it's always it's a little bit of a
finesse game you have to learn a little
bit what is important what is difficult
in what is easy when you're playing at
sea but in terms of hybridizing whether
you play an entirely land civ entirely
water sieve or both you could be equally
powerful equally competitive to litigate
so right now we're you know kind of
scouting out the land itself annecy will
there be you said they're different
monsters obviously than what we've been
used to with civilization beyond our
proper is there going to be there gonna
be a lot of different kind of resources
you can run into and see or they the
same ones but they're just in like you
can get to them faster or have to move
cities toward them so the sea has a
unique collection of resources as well
as aquatic versions of the strategic
resources like 4x site and float stone
and CMS those have to be everywhere but
like those those r chelonia and there's
vents and other strange things that live
in the ocean
and bottoms that you can like mine or
fish for that are only found at sea and
then likewise the things that you used
to find on land you can still find there
so they're improved in much the same way
so they serve a similar function but
they there you know the way that they
appear on the landscape because of the
way though the seas are generated is a
little bit different so when you when
you settle your season your cities at
sea you do have to think about where
you're going to get your resources and
how you're going to drive the city
around in a little bit of a different
way driving cities is is a huge deal for
our aquatic see the similar colony
establishment because you have to do in
order to get new territory or either
that or by the plot so you if you don't
have the energy it's the only way the
city's ever going to get bigger and it
cost production which means you have to
stop doing other things in order to do
it and when you when the game begins you
can only travel around on the shallows
the city is still a little a little
fragile you have to get some more
advanced technology before you can sail
into the deep so moving the city is
establishing a territorial foothold at
sea and like getting the civ the city
all of the the plots and the resources
it's going to need to be really powerful
is a much more active process you might
have much more pay attention to the lay
of the land especially where the aliens
are and where your competitors are
developing when you're deciding where to
put your cities it's it's much easier to
expand on land where you can just plunk
down the outpost and when it grows into
a city will just absorb the land around
it no problem in conversely do you find
that there's less pressure on where
you're establishing a sea city knowing
that you'll be able to later move it
whereas the land ones you know you kind
of just say okay this has this resources
it's coastal city it's I think it could
be easy to defend if this it came to a
militaristic situation have you found
that it's kind of a little more you know
less pressure on you to establish see
cities I think so I mean we one of the
interesting questions we faced when
balancing aquatic gameplay was sort of a
concern at the outset that actually it
would be too easy to play a sea because
like there's no terrain obstacles
there's no miasma there's nothing to
stop cities from moving around wouldn't
that be a better across the board than
playing on land and what we found and
what we ultimately were able to develop
was a really lovely balance where it's
not necessarily easier or harder it's
just different depending on the like the
way the the ocean is laid out of the way
the
and is laid out or where your
competitors are settling or where the
aliens live there could be really
lucrative spots on either one you know
lands provides that terrain obstacles
but terrain is also an obstacle for your
enemies can be pretty difficult to
attack land cities whereas navies are
really really fast yeah there's nothing
to stop them from just whipping across
an ocean and surprising an unsuspecting
sea city so aquatic cities can be really
powerful but they can also be really
delicate and they really have to be
looked after a lot more than a lance if
he does so depending on your play style
on the particular strengths of the sieve
that you're playing on a particular
stage of the game you can find things
that really power you up by playing land
or playing on sea but also things you
really got to watch out and we're with a
North Sea Alliance obviously you know
more about seafaring nation as this
could you would it be a good idea to
actually try to like focus on land if
you were going to be the civilization
are they pretty really pretty dynamic
enough to actually do that yeah it was
um when we have a sieve that's focused
on the aquatic gameplay like the north
sea lions there we had to be careful to
make sure that their advantages will not
be eclipsed tour useless if the map is
primarily land and of course you know
when you when you choose them you should
definitely make sure that the planet
that you land on is one that has oceans
otherwise they really will have very um
you know very little to offer in the way
of sort of inherent power but they're
they're special the character trade
ability is that there are aquatic cities
move faster and are inherently stronger
which is sort of like universally good
it doesn't matter where the cities are
what stage of the game it is or what's
going on you you're going to benefit
from them so they can apply their their
advantage no matter where their aquatic
cities are developed and how many of
them they have versus how many land
cities they so north sea lions could
just as easily play on land as any other
two
but with if they play at sea and if the
opponents play of C they will have a
sort of decided advantage if so while
we're in the the tech tree have you been
a few many changes to that and from what
I understand there's a little more like
you I things that you're doing
differently with this time around in
terms of like showing certain tech paths
and whatnot yeah actually this came one
of the very first and most popular mods
to the original beyond Earth was a mod
that colored all of the things that you
get from your technologies and made it
easier to read you know what what
affinities you were going to get and
what kinds of things you're going to
find so we kind of took took inspiration
from that and integrated some of that
feedback it's one of the most direct
ways our players talk to talk to us as
to mod the game one of the problems with
the tech web is that it's there's just
so much information here there's a lot
you can see and we internally debated
for a long time like would we hide some
of it and show it gradually to the
player do we hold back information or
what and force if players want to see
the whole path right because they would
go on Wikipedia and figure this out
right away anyway so they were just
frustrate our core players to hide the
information so said okay we have to show
the whole web how can we make it more
readable well we can put more color in
it we can change the shapes of the
things that you get we took a lot of
feedback there and I think came up with
a pretty good compromise it's still a
lot to take in but I think that's a
thing that our players really like is is
to learn the new lay of the land so to
speak so I've been playing here a little
bit David's taken over the controls
we've been exploring the map and we just
got a satellite there I found several
artifacts this planet is pretty artifact
rich so we just found a messiah
Stratovarius there from Old Earth it's
in great condition so that will give us
a lot of culture the artifact system is
really exciting it sort of is a growth
out of our quest system and as a way for
us to reward the player with these neat
objects that they can have and cash in
for bigger rewards so you you always
have this this risk reward sort of
long-term long-term short-term
decision-making with artifacts do I cash
in a single artifact
for a bonus right now or do I wait and
get a set of two or three for a much
larger bonus later and of course each
one has quite a bit of fiction and that
the images are beautiful and it's a
great way for us to infuse the game with
more sci-fi and world building stuff
that our players really like that was
always interesting to me is how you know
like the civilizations ourselves have
different reasons I know like somebody
wants came in a second wave or later on
wave yet while exploring all of them did
actually they're sort of their more what
we say is there rougher around the edges
so after the great mistake there was the
original wave the first wave of the
eight that you know of and that was the
base game and then these guys came along
you know maybe 50 years later they
stayed behind and had to deal with earth
whereas everyone else kind of took off
right so they don't really have a chip
on the shoulder I'd say but they
certainly have to head to deal with more
they had to do more with less so for
example alpha la who's a leader will see
in short order probably there their
whole civilization grew out of the
Middle East the ruins of the Middle East
and they came back or they came to the
new world in a generation ship as
opposed to being asleep the whole time
so their whole culture is built in a
fundamentally different way and that is
reflected their gameplay David was very
adamant we have a Scottish a leader in
Duncan Hughes he could he could probably
speak to their their origins as well
yeah the M when we were establishing the
aquatic gameplay as a foundational idea
for rising tide we definitely wanted
factions that would emphasize it so we
have four two factions two of them
emphasize the seed the north sea lions
is one of them the the other one is yet
to be revealed so north the Alliance was
we grew out of just a lot of enthusiasm
around the the design group for I guess
naval history maritime naval history and
so and also the fact that in the base
game the Nordic countries in Great
Britain were not represented they were
not specifically called out so that was
an obvious blood was a match made
Great Britain and its history on the
Seas and then sort of the Scandinavian
likewise with going even further back to
this there Viking heritage like this
could be an awesome combination and so
North the Alliance was was established
as a faction and then personally because
my family is Scottish by heritage and a
big fan of the idiosyncrasies of
Scottish culture I wanted the leader to
be a Scot and so and so he was so there
are a lot of fun to play a lot of fun to
play against because Duncan Hughes is
such a character so how would you
characterize him describe him are you
can take a look at me yeah it's very
like like he's very scrappy like
scrapping like it's sort of like rough
he's described as being kind of like a a
workman use for the Union level labor
level guy turned politician you know
there's a strong tradition of this in
that I think in British history of like
Scott's being kind of under doggish in
their in their political political lives
though certainly not always and so he's
got this he's got his very air of being
very rough like bare knuckled and sort
of does everything with his own hands
kind of air about him he also wears the
Sega Genesis for a belt it's kind of
great costume is why is these largest
like the physically ill the largest
leader and his personality is very kind
of like in-your-face kind of blunt
no-nonsense doesn't like doesn't really
get spooked very easily is not easily
scared he's sort of seen at all kind of
thing and he's so he's very he's very
devoted to his particular agenda which
is like establishing this aquatic Empire
and I'm safeguarding his population but
he can be a really really loyal friend
like this these are some things that
were able to reflect in the new
diplomacy system does these personality
quirks of Lee how suspicious a person is
or how likely they are to maintain
respect for you once they've reached it
how easily scared they are so he's a
either he's a fun guy to have as a
friend as an ally and it could be a very
tough enemy
because he's very tenacious or he's
stubborn I could see him writing a bear
or something yeah you could you like we
design and we like you can see in the
new leaders a little bit of him and
especially they are a little larger than
life a little bit more than the original
eight were they look original eight were
cut from a very kind of plausible cloth
and only like only a few of them started
to reach a little bit further on like
how they became less people and more
icons of their particular culture but
the four new leaders are much more
iconic I would say it's interesting to
see how people like Duncan or with like
you know alpha lather there what you
think of their culture back like in the
world we know it but also balancing that
with what it might be on other worlds
and like a sci-fi setting and whatnot
because it's interesting because I know
like alpha la I think I remember they're
saying like a lot of those people are
actually that are landing on these new
worlds have never been on a planet
before they are all born in space and
all of them but a lot of them is it kind
of is kind of are you going with like a
more narrative angle this with the
expansion you know more so than with you
did with beyond Earth but we definitely
don't want the we don't want the game's
narrative to supersede the players I
think that civilization the strong one
of the strongest if not the strongest
thing about this kind of game is its
ability to let players tell their own
stories and we certainly didn't want to
trample on that which is why we held
back quite a bit of the fiction
development the world building that we
did the base game that turned out not to
be a great idea I think in a sci-fi game
there's this expectation of sci-fi stuff
morale-building that you provide that is
basically given to us for free when we
make a historic suit game so we decided
to sort of double down on putting that
in the game and and designing new
mechanics that highlight it like the
artifact system each artifact you can
see has like a blurb sort of giving its
history and it's a great window into the
world that we've constructed and the
diplomacy system is similar it's a it's
a window into the the characters of
these that we've that we've created here
this is you know Matt Maz bathhouse
there you go it sounds useful sounds
gross that sounds disgusting
so that the narrative there's definitely
a lot more narrative a lot more of the
story the storytelling stuff in the
expansion but again was very important
the players story is the most important
sure I usually I think my my default
strategy and most hideous to kind of go
for the cultural angle but every once in
a while and I think military might be a
good way to go I always kind of say all
right I wouldn't normally go this way
but I'd really like this time if I could
just you know roleplay as that
militaristic you know just crazy leader
that just takes over everything is path
and that's always mostly when the games
become really interesting to me well
that's what we're gonna try to do I
think in this game awesome force poop no
not yet yeah we're gonna set up instead
of a scrap with somebody close by you
look France why not perfect so we'll
like we'll go for a military angle and
in sort of woman course they seem to be
oh yeah like you said there are a lot of
these artifacts scattered around well
this were this is an unusually high rate
I mean we're getting we're getting them
a bit faster than we I don't
statistically would but it's still yeah
you depending on how much exploration
you doing whether you hit a lot of
resource pods and sites and things you
can find lots of it so we've hoovered up
a lot of resource pause which means
we've gotten a lot of older with
artifacts it's different useful but
there's a lot of powered we found on the
other ones the alien ones and then the
progenitor ones which we haven't really
gotten much of it
do you like I go back getting tons of
older with artifacts she's definitely
useful it's good for us yeah stick that
in the furnace and make some science up
so as one does so we're going for for a
naval say that we're going for a war
gotta have some so one of the one of the
most fun parts about designing the
aquatic expansion was bringing back and
sort of reflect out the naval military
options like navies are fun they're fun
game to play if done right and it's
always been a little disappointing to me
in historic see how long it takes to get
your navies really going because well
frankly we didn't sail that well until
many thousands of years after
civilization was established but that's
not the case and futuristic game you can
get on the season right away and aquatic
gameplay wasn't that big of a deal in
base PE so you had kind of a
one-size-fits-all naval unit and then a
carrier and that was good enough but
with all this stuff there is to do and
all the competition happening on the
Seas the Navy's had to compete so
there's more than like there's several
classes of neo units carriers are a lot
more elaborate there's a lot more
hovering units which are and piteous you
know they just slide back and forth so
that armies eventually become terrain
agnostic but we also brought back
submarines and the concept of
invisibility which is a lot of fun in
military conflict so submarines in Baton
civ5 had invisibility of a type and we
sort of simplified and expanded the
rules a little bit to be a little more
universal because we also have
invisibility on some land units a couple
of the hybrid affinities have unique
units are also invisible and that can be
really fun but submarines are now a huge
deal like you really need them for an
effective Navy especially for an
effective siege of aquatic cities
because they with the way that
everything moves in the way that navies
are much more of like an active defense
as well as an act of offense to take an
aquatic city is as much a function of
taking out as protective Navy as it is a
city itself and submarines are
invaluable for that because of their
ability to to hide to ambush to pick off
and then vanish into the Seas you can
whittle down somebody's Navy without
them being able to respond because
navies are
a little bit more expensive a little
more difficult to maintain every ship
lost is that much of a bigger blow plus
against the aliens who have no concept
of submerged units and invisibility
submarines can be invaluable so if we
get a few subs out there and a couple
gunboats to back them up will start to
clamp down on the expansion ambitions of
Franco Iberia to our north and then we
can augment that with a land army to
follow up and corine take out their
capital or try to we will try to do that
so if you're going for a military sing
angle and arm is still pretty essential
as far as well not necessarily I'm
saying that for Frank library because
they're built on land of our Navy's
can't can't capture their cities alone
but I'm playing we said we were going to
play to our strengths first Duncan
Hughes and NSA are unable civ so getting
a naval naval superiority is going to be
easier for them across the board so I
could jump on that advantage while we
can and then you were going to leverage
that into like amphibious power once
we're preventing Frank Liberia from
retaliating you know Park are ranged
units off the coast shoot shoot at the
the land units as a mill around and then
when the the path is clear we'll land a
few well-placed Marines and seach units
and take out the city you mentioned the
diplomacy options earlier is that
something want to get into later yeah no
we can do that now actually we have so
we've been slowly accumulating a new
yield called diplomatic capital we have
149 we're making 5 a turn diplomatic
capital is the fundamental yield that
drives the diplomacy system now that
we've met a few leaders while we've met
one liter the one we planted the one we
plan to fight under so diplomacy does a
few things the first thing that it does
is it makes the characteristics of your
of yours or your leaders very important
and the characteristics are take the
form of these things called traits which
give the character some unique spin or
ability or predilection so we have
we have one character trait that's
always there Dave pronounce this word
indefatigable there you go tell these
LuAnn theism define it for me it means
untiring or never ever exhausted never
fatigued integrity we're trying to raise
the level of discourse in the we were
for excess we're very high falutin it's
actually the long long and much beloved
name of British warships like there's
been many indefatigable throughout their
history I didn't know that there's like
the enterprise or the current you know
the constitution for the United States
well to other people that play this game
will appreciate this i'm somebody
somewhere one per hope is now really
excited that I know that and care about
that sort of thing he brings it up at
dinner parties whatnot right did you
know you know think about a long line of
British ships um so anyway throughout
the game as you as you accumulate this
currency you can spend it to upgrade
your character's personality and you can
you can buy with it up to three
additional traits political military and
domestic trades and these we don't have
we actually need one more point to buy
this and in times if you advance the
term lord I can write yeah let's do that
actually so is there an effort to make
it very clear what you're going for and
diplomacy and where you're headed
because of you know what you have these
it's like currency almost that's kind of
right increasing certain traits with
other characters and leading you towards
certain you know hopeful solution well
diplomacy does a lot of different things
you can you can expand your personality
your the AI players are expanding their
personality you can make agreements with
other AI you can or other players I
should say you can change the
relationship you have with other players
so let's go through this i can make
agreements with Elodie she's got to hear
think tanks and film philanthropy each
which gives me different bonuses these
are big sort of civilization wide
bonuses I can afford one I can't afford
the other or I can change our
relationship so you'll kind of recognize
this from civ 5 and beyond Earth but
it's sort of different like the
relationships being in a relationship
means more in this in this game so as my
relationship with a sieve gets better
the agreements that we have
together get better the things that I
can do our trade our trade routes get
more effective lots of different things
happen so we can spend our diplomatic
capital to change the relationship and
provided the leader either is very
afraid of me or respects me a lot they
will agree to that so we don't need a
change our relationship is again we're
going to go to war with her in a bit but
you're right basically the diplomacy
system kind of brings a degree of
transparency to what the AI does like so
many times and civ I've played and the
AI is backstab me or gone to war all of
a sudden for no particular reason and
there actually is a particular reason
under the hood there's lots of math
going on the decides that assumes should
go to war or not and what we've done is
we sort of brought a little bit of that
math a little bit of those numbers up
front so the player can see them and
strategize around them and also through
the traits you can predict what things
that a sieve will like what things thats
it won't like and cater to those things
if you want them to like you more seems
sort of similar to how the tech tree you
kind of you know like outline things a
little more transparently yeah
information I think that's that's a key
for us and it's always tricky because
like the check tree is a good example we
didn't want to bombard players
particularly new players with too much
information but we need to have just
enough so David is just stumbled upon
one of the another new feature in the
expansion called marvels and these are
these huge structures or natural
formations on the planets that you'll
find so we found this giant crater and
another one and another smaller one so
the idea here is that once you find the
big one it's revealed to all of the
other players on the map at a quest is
started for everyone ads and the quest
is to find some number of the smaller
ones so there's a big one and they're
always smaller ones and once you find
all the smaller ones you get this quest
reward which can color the rest of your
game it's usually a pretty big benefit
in the case of the meteor there if we
find I think three more of them yeah we
get a huge production boost and if we
find additional ones we get more
production so the prime primordial biome
maps can always be production focused
because that particular marble shows up
in the primordial
world so that's one of the ways that we
give these maps their own unique spin is
through the Marvel system also the AI is
slightly different with the aliens the
aliens stats alien behaviors are
different planet as well okay yeah like
you said you mentioned you were going to
attack Frank Liberia so you might not
want to waste the you know the diplomacy
points on them yeah actually we can spin
them to upgrade our own traits at this
point or find an ally on the map at some
point to spend the capital to make
agreements with them which would you
think we could do I was I don't know
we're close to getting a few other
people on the map but it's still really
early there may not have a lot to offer
right I think we might be better off
with that freight we don't have plus
will set us up to to sell some right so
we you have four categories of traits
you can have for activating one time
character trait is always your like
unique to your leader you always have
that you can't change it you can just
make it better so the other three are
like depending on on what you're focused
on you can pick a trait that that
augments a particular portion of your
civilization so the domestic ones focus
on your individual yield output you
microwave your active active citizens do
the political ones tend to focus on your
relationships with other sibs and
they're a lot of their effects have to
do with how many agreements you're
maintaining or what happens when you
maintain them and then military
obviously is about how you want your
your tactical operations or strategic
operations to function so you your
Realtor to be better to be faster to be
cheaper more numerous or experienced
more about defense more about offense
and so on today I want to fight let's
pick a military treatment all right
let's pick the efficient one so that we
can build them easily so this will give
us plus 50 at the first level it will
give us plus 15 production for military
units will be able to build military and
it's much faster now when you select a
trait you also get agreements which
other sibs can buy from you so your
trade is not just benefits for you but
also benefits for others as well if they
decide to make these agreements so the
agreement that that this one provides is
private arms development production
costs for military units are used so by
selecting a trade your simultaneously
taking on a style for your own sip like
you're specifically sculpting your
playstyle to say my
am i safe to be good at these things to
be maybe the best at them but also to be
about them as far as the other leaders
are concerned so they can look like you
say oh this guy is emphasizing
military's guys emphasizing commerce and
birth emphasizing research whatever it
is all right Dave got your submarines
all right he's next wow you more science
we do need to learn to go genetics Oh
pick up a Klansman the M the other
leaders can look at those traits and I
get agreements that match them so
likewise if somebody else in the world
had picked efficient I can say oh
they're emphasizing large military
because they're picking a trait that
makes it easier for them to build if I
ever want to build a big army would I
would do well to be friends with that
guy and and harness the agreement that
they offer to get a little bit of that
power so the the diplomatic character
you take on not only augments your
individual sit but it also makes you a
particular style particular kind of
friend to have in the actual world so
that if you're playing a game and you're
watching the diplomatic landscape you
can make friends with the people who are
good at the things you're not good at
they can plug the holes in your sieve
that you need plugged without you having
to develop the infrastructure or spend
the time to do it yourself so that was a
big deal for the new diplomacy system
was making it relevant to the whole game
and making it so that you can use it to
express your sibs identity and you can
solve real problems that you really have
so not just for instance trading
individual units of energy or resources
but actually expressing values and
identity on a grand scale and really
making it about like the meeting of
minds of nations and not sort of the
wheeling and dealing of on a micro level
like like you would do a trade round so
the fact that we took on this trait
means that we have this agreement
available which hopefully other people
will buy from us and we will start to
get diplomatic capital from that which
will power up our diplomacy our
capabilities will be able to make our
traits better take on new ones make more
agreements like it's a self-reinforcing
system the more diplomacy you do the
more there is
it's all very clear as to what goal
you're working toward if you need to
supplement your military then you know
that okay this little alliance with
benefit me in this area so I can focus
on culture or vice versa because like
you said there's that transparency with
the diplomacy system now and the other
leaders and it's less unpredictable but
still very much you know like like it
seems like i'll be able to definitely
have a firmer grasp on controlling those
diplomacy's if I can do have control in
the first place just you know because
whereas the leaders used to there was
the complex math on the surface I mean
kind of working them towards certain
actions and reactions but now you're
like okay i see why they did that or i
see why that we're not allied anymore
right so yeah so and you can watch them
do the same thing like go through the
same thought process the leaders will
pick traits that are reflections of
their needs in a particular situation so
you know LD may have she starts with a
rather than herpa character trait which
is focused on culture that's her sort of
spin and then depending on like if she
gets in a war with us which is going to
happen then the trace you could pick
could end up being very military or
production phase because that's the
world that she lives in that she needs
to deal with that which could change the
way her civilization grows up over time
which could change and turn the way
other leaders view her like she could
become the other military sieve and
another leader in the game that maybe
would have been predisposed to do that
we'll see oh I don't need to rather just
make a deal with Elodie or with us and
they can they can change interval way so
it's got all these wonderful ripple
effects with the leaders will respond to
the changing circumstances on the ground
pick traits or change trades based on
what's going on and how to best sort of
surf the wave of a power and opportunity
and then if you're like I said if you're
watching that you're if you're playing
the diplomacy game you can see those
trends establishing you can see them the
leaders picking like that and you can
you can
you ate them so it can be really
satisfying pull off like elaborate
schemes and sort of long-term strategic
plays with particular leaders pitting
them against each other or guiding one
in a certain way to be sort of your your
sidekick and do the things you're not
good at you make them make them serve
your ends you get this Explorer back to
my city he's out of modules and at this
guy refilled yeah so I'm trying i have
this agreement wait yeah so I let me get
the pot here I'm I want to get some I'm
gonna get some more artifacts probably
here we go okay let's see what we can
get science it's not a lot though
that's more getting there that's us even
less I would break down the two together
again Janet the later so as you saw
there were sort of like making sense in
the artifact system is sort of
exploratory the rewards you get is are a
function of the categories of the guard
effects not the individual artifacts so
the fact that there were two earth ones
and one progenitor one was was giving us
a certain an option from a certain
subset of options we had alien artifacts
so if we had more pertinent or artifacts
this would have been different and then
every every sort of every every time you
get a new artifact or every time you're
interested in a quick gain looking at
your artifacts for whether or not it's a
good time to break down one for
immediate power or whether you should
keep hoarding them in the hopes of a set
you know you constantly have that
decision we've already made two really
good set buys and gotten two unique
buildings these are buildings that are
only accessible via artifacts so those
are going to be good at me big leg up
legs up I think the one we got right
away the frontier Stadium lets our
military units start with a free
promotion which is going to be even
better once we get into this Warren
we're building military that are
starting out of the gate stronger could
you describe to me a situation which
that would prompt you to move your city
if you were a naval city sorry I'm busy
fighting city as a like strategically
yeah I've done it a few times here yeah
I'm kind of hugging the coast basically
the the reason you move cities is to
gain territory and new resources so you
kind of when you plant a land city use
your calculus is kind of like I see the
city growing in a circle but you really
have to plan the path your city is going
to take more carefully when you build or
when you're moving the city and there
also you also have to plan for it to not
drive over things that are important so
it drives over an improvement it
destroys it this so you know there'd be
very careful how you how you build your
improvements so geometrically will that
kind of make the sea cities a little
different shaped rather than just this
growing amorphis blob I really like
making thing yeah I mean
can paint whatever shape you want and
that can that can be used to your
strategic advantage we can paint we
could potentially paint all the way over
her to her front door here and you know
be be right next door if we wanted to
she wouldn't be very happy about that
but you could do that all right what do
you think I should do here dave gets us
ladies so that you can go free promotion
that's a great idea yeah and actually
the great moving water cities as sort of
a form of tactical offense is one of the
interesting side effects of moving water
seas at all because the city is
extremely powerful compared to any
military unit but it's also really
fragile and it's old it's a big risk if
you drive it into a war zone without
proper protection so the fact that we
can relatively close to her capital is
on the surface a good thing but we only
have one city right now and it's our
capital so we can't afford to lose that
so driving that right up to her front
door and starting like a very very close
quarters war could work out really well
for us but if we'd go south we have it's
going to be very hard for our capital to
escape and water cities start off
inherently weaker on defense than
Lansing's I mean obviously because
they're just a lot more fragile they can
sink they don't have the benefit of
terrain to anchor tube so in a pitched
battle our capital kept probably cannot
out-compete hers unless we were really
emphasizing military so what would be
probably wise is this was a little later
in the game we would have a second city
now we would would form that into like a
fortress city actually I was just going
to say we have enough money to enough
energy to buy a colonist did you
research pioneer no no I need a research
minor right so we could set up that this
one it was a sort of a longer slower
strategy would you would think about
that in a sort of like a grand war that
was very protracted because cities move
very slowly so you can't like can't
launch a surprise attack with the city
right now it's still much better given
all of our advantages that are piling up
four units it's much better to me like
make it really strong Navy and go and
just start pounding her from from the
sea and then have the few Marines ready
to do the final song what do you think
here um
well I mean what's under that what's
available on might Justin do it increase
production yeah i mean that's that we
already have heard yeah we already have
a trait that will do that so this will
double down so our military unit
production once we start to build them
is gonna be right through the roof I
think is I think we've got enough
advantages now that as soon as the
frontier stadium is done we should we
should start all right we'll build a
tall city right and just roll out now do
we want to unlock one more type of unit
before we prosecute this war we've got
the naval fighter and the naval melee
right or do we want to get a bump in
some some affinity first yeah that would
really benefit we're we're at equal XP
on all three yep so anything that's
cheap what's looks like it's like
nothing's of that to you I mean alien
life-forms is a good pic power systems
power systems is a good pick i think i'd
go for power season yeah alright so
that'll be a little while before that's
done how about ready to go against
Franco iberia yeah so one can build a
start building units and we'll have them
ready when the I have like three or four
ready one sure XP you can build a
submarine yeah those are so submarines
they also attacks cities not just enemy
ships sure yeah I mean they're enable
unit so they they can only attack what
they can get close to you so if the city
isn't on the coast to suffering probably
can't reach it but they are rain to it
yes the invisibility rules are such that
the sub is invisible as long as it hides
but as soon as you attack with it it's
spotted for the remainder of the turn so
subs are good for like surprise attacks
in groups like sort of a wolf pack style
mentality where you you surprised three
or four of them and ones do enough
damage to take out the unit that would
be doing a reprisal and then the next
turn they'll vanish again
on their own on solo you really only
want to do it unless if you're sure that
you have you have at least a numerical
even playing field because then because
getting the first attack by being a
invisible unit will will tip it in your
favor immediately and then you can
survive but if the if the sub is
outnumbered it can be very easy to take
out because it's not that fast compared
to any surface ship drive across it was
in the fog of war
so you were talking about different
editions with this expansion you may
have diplomacy obviously is seafaring
the map is greatly expanded we're also
talking about hybrid affinities could
you you want to go into that at all or
talk about that or there'd be a better
time to do so no that's fine I don't
think we're going to get to actually
build a hybrid if in a hybrid unit here
in a hundred turns or so there it's a
it's a mid to late game change so
basically if you recall from the base
game the affinity system was this way
that that we show how humanity adapts to
the new world and that's mainly
reflected in your in your military but
in other ways too but it basically
boiled down to something that resembled
an RPG class system we were allocating
or sure you're sort of gaining points in
different class types and were unlocking
new abilities and in those classes and
it came with the same kinds of problems
which is you could like if you build a
diablo 2 character incorrectly you know
you can really hose yourself later on
and so they were builds that you could
get into high affinity builds that were
not quite as advantageous and that kind
of fights this idea of the exploratory
techweb and the kind of role-playing
that we want you to do as a player of
beyond Earth so we added the hybrid
affinities to fix that problem so if you
so you no longer have to worry about
getting the wrong affinity because you
want the tech in the tech web you can
play and sort of get whatever text you
want and naturally those will unlock
those combinations of affinities well
not these hybrid units which are very
powerful the unique hybrid units are are
pretty cool and that they they sort of
augment your military they're not really
frontline troops but they do some really
weird things like David mentioned we
have a land unit that's invisible that's
a hybrid unit hybrid unique and your
base unit classes also have their top
tier upgrade and the upgrade tree for
those units has a
has three hybrid variations so you can
have an entirely hybrid army and that's
great and it's very effective one of our
instructions to our art team and indeed
to ourselves when we were designing
these guys is that we didn't want the
hybrids to be just averages of the three
affinities that we already had in Game
they each have their own philosophical
take their own art style their own
personality and they're very cool i wish
we had more time with you today so that
we could play to the point we can get
one but they're sort of mid to late game
things you could see here in terms of
RPG mechanics and kind of finding a
balance between being a hybrid and not
being an average that kinda reminds me
of the mass effect when you're making a
character not that it's that much
similar of a game but you know you can
have like the biotic in this Thank You
Sentinel as opposed to just an average
of these two it still had their own
abilities wow that's that's exactly the
kind of thing we were shooting for I
think the first right answer is just to
kind of blend and in some ways that's
the case but it's definitely especially
from the art perspective they're totally
different they look totally different
when we get a unit upgrade here once
this this tech refinishes research once
power systems is done we can show a few
of the hybrids in the upgrade screen did
you finish the requested you just finish
I'm about to finish that reason is not
business or convene hearthstone ok
I feel like I can get so he was oh happy
to read my mind quest I got my sub out
here one of the things we added to the
HUD was a soul eyeball overlay that it
shows you where the sub would be
revealed is ok so that and so it's an
extra little tool for the player to keep
their subs or keep anything visible unit
in ambush position do not accidentally
move it to a place where it would be
caught out in so the other player can't
see that sub he is cloaked he's
invisible until until I have a movement
system into some area that would reveal
him or fight with it right
as I all daddy's about to expand this
may be a good opportunity do you think I
could cost about that back i think im
gonna she'd go for her second city I
just yep which is the second sub it
starts with a combat abilities awesome
nice is that from the frontier Stadium
yeah
so what is about those spaces that would
reveal you is that the monster just
sitting right there yeah the fact that
like the visibility you're always
revealed if you're adjacent to a hostile
unit oh just sort of drove right into
your left there like right now I've got
got two subs so this guy is still
invisible because it's not hostile so
it's funny you're like you're innocent
until proven guilty with invisible units
you don't reveal them to anybody on
purpose they have to be actively trying
to find them before they'll find them
okay now I've got a gunboat as well so
I'm actually in pretty good shape to
start this fight a gun boating two subs
that's gonna go a long way let's open up
diplomacy and break the bad news but
mean you talk to you so she's actually
pretty impressed with us you see her her
fear is relatively low which suggests
that her military might actually be a
match for ours but not at sea I don't
think she's man
so you'll notice that as we do certain
things in the game you'll see these
little communicate call them pop up in
the top there those are like little text
messages that the the leaders are
sending to you very very much like how
politics and diplomacy is conducted in
the modern era really yeah it's another
way that the diplomacy system kind of
highlights the personalities of each of
these characters they all have their own
pretty deep library of things that they
say to you depending on what you're
doing so she is pissed off oh man get
that thing ford escapes those things I'm
spotted now because there's a hostile
units Jason so since it's already
spotted I may as well shooting with it
and not expose my other son which
doesn't know I had two subs that
columnist his toes nice
good start hmm my gun boat in position
and try to start picking off anything
that comes out of that city can't get to
closer it'll shoot with the city you
know but it should be able to hold down
yep right away get back in there and
Bart units are still really vulnerable
for land armies so the I'm invisible
again if I i can i can actually park
within sight range of the city and still
remain invisible with us up which makes
it really really cool because if I like
array a bunch of subs out here you know
lurking in the depth you can't see any
of them unless you put some naval unit
at sea and then they can all attack on
the same term like I said that wolf pack
thing really like pop out i'll fire off
the city only has time to reprisal
against one and then they all vanish
again just really satisfied whereas a
gunboat the big honking battleship you
would definitely see that so i'm just
gonna kind of keep that just outside
range into a little patrolling may be
able to pillage too yeah if I get an
opportunity again yep expedition
get on this brain while I can
and so all the while I get at this point
when you're at war with Franco Iberia
would it be it would be seems like it'd
be pretty advantageous to find another
leader and see if their strengths can
either augment your military or just
having a life of them could kind of fill
any gaps you might have while you're at
war with Frank Liberia absolutely so one
of the things that can suffer I mean it
you can do one of two things right you
can get something to bolster the war
there you're fighting or you know when
you're fighting a war yours by necessity
kind of collecting your domestic growth
so you can also get through the
diplomacy system get boosts to that as
well so we just met baraye and he he's a
growth sieve and tends toward growth
type traits so if we were behind the
curve in growth and health or anything
like that we can go to him for some help
oh look at that there's a makara already
wrecking things in her territory that's
why she's being she's building so much
so many military she's got anti-alien
operations going so this this could work
out really well for us if he's
distracted by that we could be in a
position to sac liquor or a faster than
I would have thought I'm building
soldiers over here for the amphibious
push that I sort of staged them over
here on the continents and get ready to
embark them when our city is reduced or
when it's focused too much on taking out
my Navy deal that final blow yeah so I
tried to pillaging there I couldn't
escape in time so I took a shot but I'll
get out next time
those guys one you just wouldn't
we finish the marble quest which means
now we have a big bump in production for
a finite period of turrent of time and
everyone knew one of these creators we
find we can sort of you can resurrect or
or extend that bump but that is actually
true for everybody now that the sort of
secrets of the Marvel are known the
whole planet can use it so anybody else
can get the same production benefit
benefit for themselves and they have to
they have to complete the quest right so
it's kind of a race to see who can get
to it first but it's not mutually
exclusive so anyone can find all of the
minor marbles and complete the quest but
we're the first people to do it I think
I haven't seen anybody else going for
them yet so we're going to get a big
production boost here if we can find
more of those things okay all right
there we go if in any progress so I've
at level 2 supremacy and get a couple
several that can be upgraded noon-4 make
things a lot stronger
brand new okay Marines standing around
it's interesting that the hybrid
affinities are also kind of like you
said mid to late game because I think
historically or at least you know like
earlier games it was those first like
fifty hundred turns are really really
interesting so hybrid affinities it's
interesting that are coming in later it
seems like another thing that could
completely change and we can actually
show a couple of them Dave once you
click on ya got this before you so I
built home i actually have double
progress in they built all those
soldiers so yeah looking at the gunboat
here the hybrids look like are really
really quite beautiful the Barras
superimposing because they don't have a
defending yet but you could kind of see
behind it they've got their own style
like if that's harmony this is the
harmony supremacy crossover and this is
a harmony purity crossover you know
purity good vote and impurity surprise
as we're always looking at ways to
extend you know extend gameplay like I
think one of the classics of problems is
that once you've explored the whole map
the kind of the interest drops and you
want to reroll any map so we've
introduced a lot of new mechanics
throughout not just in beyond Earth but
throughout you know the civ 5 product
line to extend the gameplay to extend
interest new things come online as the
game progresses that that you're going
to be interested in we want to maintain
that one more turn loop as long as we
can all right Dave what are we doing I'm
getting ready to jump on the attack so I
want my gun boat to heal up and I want
my Marines ready and I'm gonna shoot
cover their approach I don't know if
I've got enough yet I think that Oh hope
she's still not taking me seriously
she's got he's a colonist coming up
she's definitely not only your footing
and it's not afraid of you I wonder if
she has another city somewhere maybe I
mean I haven't explored that comment I
suppose it could be one or hidden in
here but I think I feel like I feel like
we would see the borders yeah I think
she's just maybe her fears higher now of
course we're at war so all that stuff is
kind of disconnected you don't really
get to see another sivs fear or respect
when you're at war cuz the ideas before
you not maintaining diplomatic relations
you're not exactly talking though you
don't get any sort of any sort of
insight like that okay
just parked the hair from weep wait for
him to come out much she had a pretty
bad start location to she's on this
little spit of land but a land city so
she has to go out in the water right and
we will be there waiting plays right
into our hands futuristic block haters
exactly yeah we can see each pretty
effectively now ah here's Lena this is
uh Lena one of our other new faction
leaders she's a leader integer each is a
diplomacy um themed faction of sort of
German origin and she's got a bunch of
traits already actually she's a good
Ally to have in diplomacy because her um
her diplomatic options are stronger than
most fear she's very flexible and very
powerful get mines up in them who she
can make agreements with and how she can
make them so I went Ronaldo to my gun
leave out yet [ __ ] I met everybody
right zoom when we're picking our allies
she can be am you got to be a really
good one to have full really terrible
depending on like how she is positioning
herself so you have enough above like
the diplomacy point save up to if they
had something you really wanted at this
point you could just go for it right now
yeah yeah the son of it we have a about
170 maybe we could get something to help
us fight this war so check all the
potential agreements oh wow so these are
bees are based on whatever one's traits
are so the more traits they take on the
more agreements are in the marketplace
so to speak so what would be good for us
let's see I mean we can get something
that will boost power production maybe
we can I mean look at Reginald those
traits
these are mostly defensive like
colonists and outposts improvements the
castle doctrine of course we can also
made we can make our own traits better
yeah so that may be a better option at
this point in the other thing I would
consider would be shock-and-awe but I
don't that's a little too expensive you
pillage an attack I mean because that
way I could take out our territory and
fight the city at the same time great
but well it's not a protracted campaign
yet so I'd rather just make our
transport we can upgrade one we have or
take around take any one of these here
we go
is there all domestic focused so I think
we actually need more energy if we're
going to maintain a standing army which
takes maintenance it's really
interesting how the diplomacy is almost
just like it's a separate skill tree
entirely outside of tech now but it's
also you know the product of cooperating
or not cooperating with these other
characters it's definitely a separate
progression and that's exactly what we
wanted to build was we wanted to take
personality and make it a progression so
the personalities of every sieve and
what those personalities converge to
over the course of the game is really
important where we get our power from
who we ally with is going to be very
dependent on that personality lane of
flexing her diplomatic muscle she hired
our agreement from us for private arms
development so now we're going to make a
lot more capital return which is really
good we're going to give it we're going
to recover the whole debt that we just
spent quickly we'll be able to buy some
critical agreements and your trade level
up sewing time is right so are there any
other affections you haven't talked
about that you want it to today well
there's one faction we haven't announced
yet okay and it's the remaining aquatic
themed faction not not themed early but
but the remaining faction that can land
by defaults on water okay we're not
announcing that today but there's one
more that we're going to talk about
missing that everybody by the next few
weeks hopefully yeah probably in the
next few weeks you'll hear about it I
got shot because you put those years to
see in these bottles
yeah we've got press my luck a little
too much by hovering that close to her
you can see
getting bounced out gorilla escape here
yeah but no boat this guy just outside
of City striker engine name right back
nice of satisfying yeah those embark
units are really weak they're really
perfect targets for submarines they have
no way of knowing that you're there
until they're right on top of them and
then they're way too fragile is slow to
know exactly what submarines were
originally developed shooting down
transport ships well I hate to cut the
sea short because I'm rooting for you
that's okay but I think that's all the
time we have today that's too bad we
well we got a few licks and we're
definitely about to go for the city but
we'll assume you eat Frank Liberia and
then everyone else does just pretty good
ask forward and right right the next
hundred terms of history of this game so
the Great War ended quickly we consumed
Franco Iberia became a naval power house
and took over the world that was uh that
was rising tide in a nutshell I guess
yeah definitely anyway anybody watching
thank you so much for joining us David
mcdonnen will miller here and
civilization beyond her the rising tide
the major expansion comes out october
ninth and in the next few weeks
hopefully we'll hear about that last
seafaring civilization and thanks for
joining us have a good day
you